tach zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live im live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussionen den
ermittlungsbehörden ist ein gewaltiger
schlag gegen die organisierte
kriminalität weltweit gelungen aber auch
vor allem hier in deutschland
gestern wurden 150 objekte in ganz
vielen bundesländern durchsucht mehr als
70 personen wurden dabei festgenommen
und den wird insbesondere drogen und
waffenhandel vorgeworfen
das ganze war teil einer weltweiten
aktion insgesamt 16 länder hatten sich
daran beteiligt und den ermittlungen als
700 objekte wurden dort durchsucht und
mehr als 800 personen wurden
festgenommen
das ganze unter der leitung von
europoles europol operation treu und
schielt greenlight wo das ganze genannt
also sowas die trojanisches schild geht
aber vor allem auch auf das
amerikanische fbi zurück und vor dem fbi
gebäude in washington steht jetzt mein
kollege elmar theveßen
aber wie ist denn diese mit den
ermittlungsbehörden dieser schlag dieser
internationale schlag gelungen
das ist ein ganz spannender coo der den
da gelungen ist in den letzten jahren
sie haben im jahr 2018 oder eine
verschlüsselte plattform geknackt und
haben damals auch eine razzia gegen
diese plattform gemacht und dabei fiel
ihnen auf dass dem verbrecherbanden rund
um den globus nicht nur eigene
plattformen sondern auch eigene
endgeräte sowie unsere handys benutzen
um eben verschlüsselt miteinander zu
kommunizieren und dann ist dem fbi und
seinen partner und rund um den globus
gelungen eine eigene app zu erschaffen
die eben verschlüsselte kommunikation
ermöglicht und diese app in denen ich
sag mal markt hineinzubringen diesem
fall den markt für verbrecherbanden
das hatte offenbar geklappt besonders in
den letzten zwei jahren und auf diese
weise konnte das fbi durch eine
eingebaute hintertür die jeweils eine
kopie von jedem also eine kopie von
jeder einzelnen kurznachrichten
versendet worden ist zwischen
verbrechern in drogenkartellen
beispielsweise bei waffenlieferanten und
vielen anderen die in geldwäsche und
andere aktivitäten verwickelt sind und
auf diese weise konnte das fbi
beweismaterial sammeln man hat partner
rund um den globus eingeschaltet und auf
diesen beweismaterial fuß jetzt eben
das was wir an diesem montag erlebt
haben also razzien rund um den erdball
insgesamt hunderte von verdächtigen
festgenommen worden sind darunter wohl
auch einige hochrangige köpfe von
einigen verbrecher kartell das ganze
klingt wirklich wie aus einem hollywood
thriller fragen dazu gerne bitte in die
kommentare oder ihr kennt das per e-mail
annette erfolgte - live at zdf.de wir
werden auch nachher mit einem experten
für organisierte kriminalität sprechen
und dort nochmal genau uns anschauen was
das eigentlich ist jetzt aber erstmal
jonas post pesch der hat noch ein paar
details für uns zusammengefasst
wenn kriminelle ihre aktivitäten
koordinieren sind sie auf sichere
kommunikationswege angewiesen
dafür werden seit einigen jahren so
genannte krypto handys verwendet die
us-bundespolizei fbi und die
australische bundespolizei fbi haben mit
einem verdeckt einen eigenen anbieter
von krypto handys für kriminelle
gestartet
in den letzten 18 monaten hat das fbi
über 300 kriminelle organisationen in
über 100 ländern mit verschlüsselten
geräten versorgt die uns erlaubten ihre
kommunikation abzuhören
das prinzip funktioniert so krypto
handys sind modifizierte smartphones
denen die meisten funktionen entfernt
wurden mit den geräten kann man weder im
internet surfen noch telefonieren
es gibt nur eine chat funktion mit der
man ausschließlich mit anderen an um
nutzern kommunizieren konnte diese jets
waren vermeintlich sicher verschlüsselt
doch das fbi baute eine hintertür ein
die es ermittlungsbehörden erlaubte die
chat in echtzeit zu entschlüsseln und
mitzulesen nachdem ermittler bei
kriminellen beliebte kommunikations
plattformen wie android und ssk
abgeschaltet hatten wechselten immer
mehr von deren nutzern zu ahnung hat
einen guten ruf unter tränen
sie haben sich die plattform gegenseitig
wegen ihrer absoluten verlässlichkeit
empfohlen
aber das hat natürlich nicht gestimmt
weil sich die kriminellen auf der
plattform sicher fühlten kommunizierten
sie offen und ohne code wörter über
verbrechen wie waffen sprengstoff und
drogenhandel raubüberfälle und sogar
auftragsmorde also wirklich ein dicker
batzen an vielen vorwürfen
mir geht es da schon eure ersten
kommentare die sagen finde ich gut die
zusammenarbeit kann klappen aber
tatsächlich dann noch mal die frage wie
lief das denn genau so viele
strafermittlungsbehörden in so vielen
ländern wie arbeiten die zusammen
also es ist ganz schwer zu sagen
inwieweit diese ermittlungsbehörden ich
sag mal breit gestreut haben also wie
viele menschen unmittelbar an den
ermittlungen beteiligt waren hier in den
usa ist das so dass sein ermittlerteam
von etwa 100 beamten plus sogenannte
linguisten also die die im grunde
genommen die unterschiedlichen sprachen
übersetzen können aus diesen
abgefangenen kurzmitteilungen die haben
sich an die arbeit gesetzt und das alles
ausgewertet
im original waren zunächst natürlich
auch die australier in erster
linie beteiligt mit ermittlungsbeamten
und dann kamen so nach und nach aus
verschiedenen ländern eben
ermittlungsbehörden dazu wie viele
beamten damit involviert waren wissen
wir nicht es ist klar je mehr davon
erfahren die mehr davon wissen desto
größer das risiko dass das ganze auflegt
und vermutlich deshalb hat man auch
schon relativ schnell jetzt jetzt
zugegriffen nachdem man besonders in den
letzten drei monaten ganz offenbar diese
app so breit gestreut hatte das sehr
sehr viele nachrichten hinein kam und
genug verwertbares die meisten
beweismaterial zusammenkam um dann jetzt
schon zu zuschlagen bevor irgendwas nach
draußen sickert jetzt gibt es ja
durchaus andere möglichkeiten
verschlüsselt miteinander zu
kommunizieren ich verweist damals auch
so apps wie telegramm nutzen terroristen
ganz gerne rad 80 hier auf youtube fragt
auch warum nicht einfach signal benutzen
auch eine beliebte app also da ist die
frage warum steigen verbrecher auf diese
speziellen crypto phones oben und nutzen
nicht einfach das was wir alle auch
benutzen können dabei die verbrecher
eben misstrauisch schon in der
vergangenheit gewesen sind gegenüber
diesen apps denn die sind ja auf jedem
handy installierbar und nicht auf ganz
besonderen geräten und so hat man eben
als besondere sicherheitsstufe in diesem
verbrecherbanden immer auch wirklich die
eigenen endgeräte die eigenen mobilfunk
geräte benutzt oder mobil handys genutzt
besser gesagt und das war ein ganz
wichtiger punkt für das fbi und die
ermittlungsbehörden sie mussten
irgendwie diese geräte also speziell
entwickelte neue kuppel handys in den
markt der verbrecherbanden hinein
streuen damit die dann tatsächlich diese
neue technologie auch genutzt haben das
hat man gemacht indem man im grunde
genommen ein kleine lichter in diesen
kartellen dann diese handys
[Musik]
weitergegeben hat gewissermaßen auf
denen auch dann diese apps installiert
waren also die kartelle nutzten
besonders diese ganz sicheren plattform
mit den eigenen geräten und ich glaube
der große durchbruch erzielt wurde
erzielt vor zwei jahren als man es vor
dem beitrag erwähnt eben mehrere andere
plattformen und apps dichtgemacht hat
durch razzien
damit wurde gewissermaßen die nachfrage
für die app vom fbi und die krypto
geräte erhöht für anna und das hat
geklappt da sind also sehr viele
verbrecher auf diese neue technologie
gewechselt sehr gute frage hier von
becketts warum wird das jetzt öffentlich
gemacht statt die verbrecher
festzunehmen und dann weiter geheim zu
halten also man könnte ja auch dann
vielleicht weiter beweise sammeln
zumindest ist das die annahme oder ist
das dann im grunde unmöglich weil dann
alle wissen ok mit diesen geräten können
wir nicht mehr kommunizieren
ja ich glaube es gibt zwei gründe da ist
in der tat je mehr eben davon wissen
desto größer die gefahr dass etwas raus
sichert und dass man dann straftaten
eben nicht mehr vereiteln kann und die
beweise zusammen sammeln kann und das
zweite ist natürlich mann hatte in der
tat gravierende straftaten bei dieser
kommunikation festgestellt nicht nur
geldwäsche und drogenhandel sondern
darüber hinaus auf verabredung zum mord
also gezielte tötungen in verschiedenen
ländern und da musste man natürlich
einschreiten um schlimmeres zu
verhindern und je häufiger man
dazwischen geht also durch razzien
solche verbrecher pläne durchkreuzt
desto eher schöpfen diese dann auch
wiederum verdacht dass auch war die
sicherheitsbehörden irgendwas was mit
höheren an ihrer kommunikation und ich
glaube das sind die beiden gründe
weshalb man jetzt zugeschlagen hat jetzt
gibt es hier eine frage ich muss noch
mal kurz schauen also war das jetzt ein
rundumschlag oder wachsen die
kriminellen wir fliegen nach vermutlich
ist das nicht der fall so das ist jetzt
ein schlag aber damit ist es hier eine
gute qualität nicht vom erdboden
verschwunden
ja das wird ja ganz platt gesagt eine
schlacht ist gewonnen aber der krieg
natürlich noch lange nicht also hier
wird das sehr martialisch auch
beschrieben in den usa ja es ist in der
tat so das ist jetzt ein schlag der wird
sicherlich die arbeit der verbrecher
kartelle ein stück weit ich sag mal
bremsen aber es wird sie nicht
langfristig aufhalten das 1
über sehr positiv daran auch noch ist
sagt dass es hier und darauf ist man
besonders stolz
man hat jetzt misstrauen gesät das heißt
wenn die kartelle weiterhin
verschlüsselte technologie nutzen wollen
müssen sie im grunde genommen immer
damit rechnen dass möglicherweise das
fbi und anderer ermittler mit lesen das
hintertürchen eingebaut worden sind es
herrscht also ein misstrauen in der
verbrecher szene in der kriminellen
szene
ja und dann ist die große frage was
machen die da wenn sie ihre
verschlüsselten handys nicht mehr nutzen
können
schicken sie wieder kuriere ich habe
vorhin im internet gelesen dass einige
schon vorstellen dass heute noch bitte
brieftauben dann eingesetzt werden also
ganz klar es wird schwerer für die
kriminellen kartelle aber es wird nicht
unmöglich und der kampf wird sicherlich
weitergehen
die geht das jetzt weitere also es gibt
jetzt ermittlungen sicher den menschen
wird einiges vorgeworfen aber ist es
denn überhaupt so einfach jetzt diesen
einzelnen individuen diese accounts
zuzuordnen die werden sie ja nicht mit
klaren namo damit personalausweis
angemeldet haben sondern vielleicht auch
irgendwelche kryptischen nicknames
benutzt haben wir das ja auch tut hier
teilweise im netz absolut und das ist
sicherlich die dickste nuss zu knacken
für das fbi aber es gibt darüber wenig
auskunft also wir wissen nicht ob sie in
irgendeiner form sicherstellen konnten
dass sie genau wussten wer da welche app
und wer welche skulptur handy benutzt
hat das vom fbi zur verfügung gestellt
worden ist aber es ist genügend
beweismaterial zusammen dass man aus der
insgesamt abgehörten kommunikation das
sind ja über 30 millionen
kurzmitteilungen die offenbar
aufgefangen worden sind dass man genug
finden kann um darauf gerichtsverfahren
zu gründen
die große frage ist ob das alles auch
vor gericht an gültigkeit hat hier in
den usa ist das kein so großes problem
also eine operation vom fbi oder auch
von geheimdiensten das material was da
zusammenkommt darf hier tatsächlich vor
gericht als beweismaterial verwendet
werden aber in deutschland und einigen
anderen europäischen ländern ist das
nicht so einfach weil eigentlich stellt
ja hier eine ermittlungsbehörde eine
falle auf und sorgt damit dafür dass
straftaten auch ungehindert für eine
weile weitergehen können während man
eben beobachtet und vor dem hintergrund
ist es fraglich ob es zum beispiel in
deutschland oder anderswo dann auch vor
gericht bestand hat dieses
beweismaterial
das werden wir erst in den nächsten
wochen und monaten erfahren über dieses
problem können wir gleich diskutieren
mit professor arndt sinn der ist experte
für organisierte kriminalität der
materie sind bis hierhin vielen dank für
ihre informationen aus washington
und für alle die nicht genau wissen was
jetzt eigentlich passiert ist hat mein
kollege stefan schlosser noch mal eine
zusammenfassung gemacht hunderte male
klickten die handschellen über 30 tonnen
drogen zahlreiche waffen und bargeld in
zweistelliger millionenhöhe wurden
sichergestellt ein teil der bilanz der
weltweiten aktion gegen die organisierte
kriminalität unter führung des
amerikanischen fbi ist es gelungen in
verschlüsselte kommunikationswege in
sogenannte crypto netzwerke einzudringen
und so die absprachen der verbrecher zu
überwachen genannt operation trojaner
schild der erfolg der operation trojaner
schild ist das ergebnis gewaltiger
innovation einsatzbereitschaft und
beispielloser internationaler
zusammenarbeit die ergebnisse sind
atemberaubend für die operation haben
die ermittler eine eigene angeblich
abhörsichere nachrichten app entwickelt
und mit hilfe von informanten unter rund
300 kriminellen organisationen mehr als
100 ländern verbreitet 12.000 dieser
handys waren im umlauf
so konnten die behörden nachrichten
chats über viele monate in echtzeit mit
lesen sie sprachen über drogen gewalt
gegenseitige anschläge über unschuldige
die ermordet werden sollten die ganze
bandbreite
es war offenbar nichts dabei zu sagen
ich brauche 1000 kilo zu dem preis sehr
dreist sie haben nicht versucht das
hinter irgendwelchen code wörtern zu
verstecken
die mafia asiatische syndikate
kriminelle rockerbanden sie alle
lieferten den ermittlern ungewollt
einblicke in ihre geschäfte bis die
strafverfolger jetzt zuschlugen auch in
deutschland wurden über 70 personen
festgenommen vor allem im zusammenhang
mit drogenhandel die ganze tragweite
dieses ermittlungserfolg es lässt sich
aber noch gar nicht absehen
darüber diskutieren wir uns sprechen wir
jetzt und kriegen viele fragen
beantwortet von professor arndt sinn der
den lehrstuhl für deutsches und
europäisches strafprozessrecht
internationales strafrecht sowie straf
rechtsvergleichung und ist experte für
organisierte kriminalität an der uni
osnabrück ich grüße sie herr professor
sinn
guten abend hat es so eine aktion also
auch so international mit diesen mitteln
in der geschichte der
kriminalitätsbekämpfung schon mal
gegeben
also wenn man sich diese aktion anschaut
viele superlative haben wir gerade vom
fbi gehört dann muss man wohl sagen das
ist beispiellos
jedenfalls in der jüngeren vergangenheit
beispiellos sieht man einmal davon ab
wie damals die templer aufgeflogen sind
und verfolgt wurden dann dürfte das wohl
eine in der neuzeit hier erst das erste
beispiel sein dass von derartiger größe
von derartiger koordination und mit dem
dort verwendeten know-how durchgeführt
wurde
was ist denn das ich sag mal was
besonders für sie ist es tatsächlich die
grösste dass so viele länder
zusammengearbeitet haben
oder ist es auch die art und weise wie
man diesen verbrechern auf die schliche
gekommen ist also eigentlich ist an
dieser aktion nichts neues das wird sich
vielleicht das überraschen denn das was
unter europol koordination und unter
federführung nehme ich mal an auch das
fbi hier stattgefunden hat kennt
blaupausen und die erste blaupause ist
die internationale kooperation unter
koordination von europol
europol ist ja die agentur in der
europäischen union die als service
behörde viele viele aktionen gegen
organisierte kriminalität monatlich muss
man sagen koordiniert mit wenigen
ländern manchmal mit mehreren ländern
und manchmal mit sehr vielen länder und
das immer erfolgreich macht das nennt
man auf der internationalen ebene die
sogenannten joint investigation teams
die so genannten chips dass die ersten
blaupausen war das ganz große rad mit
vielen ländern weiter mehr erfahrung
haben und das ist richtig euro
hat er erfahrung die zweite blaupause
ist die übernahme und infiltration
krimineller plattformen auch das kennen
wir aus dem darknet des fbi hat schon
mehrfach illegale plattformen darknet
plattformen handelsplattformen
übernommen hat sie weiter betrieben um
über diese informationen dann an die
käufer nutzer betreiber heranzukommen
und nun hat man diese blaupause genommen
und etwas upgedatet und hat gesagt okay
wir wissen dass die kriminellen
verschlüsselt kommunizieren warum
stellen wir nicht selbst eine solche
verschlüsselungssoftware und ein
entsprechendes gerät her
und diese kombination aus diesen
elementen das macht es so neu das macht
es so einzigartig jetzt wird aber doch
kriminelle ziemlich misstrauisch und
können sicher schon fast gedacht haben
dass so was passieren könnte
also da wo habe ich mich so ein bisschen
gewundert wieso war das so einfach so
vielen menschen die sich ja genau
auskennen mit dieser thematik so ein
handy unterzujubeln mit dem sie ja quasi
direkt in die polizeizentrale hinein
gefunkt haben
das ist in der tat überraschend in der
kriminellen szene herrscht natürlich
eine wäre diese währung heißt vertrauen
also muss dort einen über einen langen
zeitraum viel vertrauen aufgebaut worden
sein was ich dann netzwerk artig ford
gesponnen hat und dazu geführt hat dass
es am ende so viele nutzer gab es gab
auch schon die frage warum denn jetzt
eigentlich diese aktion erfolgt ist na
ja wir haben ja vor einigen wochen die
android-app aktion gehabt und da ist
natürlich die unterwelt jetzt unruhig
geworden und ich könnte mir gut
vorstellen dass der zeitpunkt für diese
aktion deshalb so gelegt wurde um jetzt
sozusagen den sack zu zu machen bevor
eben sich personen absetzen oder
untertauchen
ein quad müssen sie glaube ich auch noch
mal kurz erklären das hat nicht jeder
mitbekommen das ist eine vergleichbare
plattform ein vergleichbares netzwerk
gewesen ja also enkel chat
ist auch eine eine eine krypta software
mit entsprechendem mobilgerät gewesen
über das kriminelle akteure kommuniziert
haben und diese personen wurden von den
französischen behörden infiltriert diese
plattform und wann hat dann eben auch
die gesprächsprotokolle und gespräche
ausgelesen und dann verschiedenen
strafverfolgungsbehörden in der
europäischen union zur verfügung
gestellt also ein ähnlicher fall nur
dass eben die franzosen nicht selbst das
hergestellt haben sondern sie ist es
ihnen gelungen diese verschlüsselungs
software zu knacken zu infiltrieren
während eben hier nach angaben des fbi
mann selbst eine solche software nebst
endgerät hergestellt hat jetzt stellt
sich natürlich die frage wer wurde da
eigentlich jetzt erst mal vorläufig
festgenommen organisierte kriminalität
ist ja ein großes wort da haben viele so
klischees vor augen wie zum beispiel ja
clans wie bei von blogs oder mafia
familien wie in der pate oder in welche
motorrad rocker banden ich sehe auch
hier schon im chat hier auf facebook zum
beispiel kommentare wir von uwe schmitt
hätte schon viel früher hätte man dann
handeln müssen man hat die kleinst
jahrelang gewähren lassen und dann haben
sie sich auch noch im staat
sozialleistungen erschlichen also hier
so eine fokussierung quasi auf nur diese
sogenannte kleinkriminalität sind das
richtige klischees oder was ist
eigentlich diese organisierte
kriminalität wenn sie die
wissenschaftliche versuchen zu fassen
also organisierte kriminalität hat viele
gesichter und vorherrschend in den
köpfen sind klischees nicht bei den
strafverfolgungsbehörden sondern eben
auch durch filme wie der pate wie vor
blogs und so weiter sind da die chefs
vorherrschend vielleicht von den mafia
organisationen bis hin zu roger
organisationen bis hin eben zu klaren
strukturen ja das gibt es alles das bin
ich überhaupt nicht abstreiten aber wenn
wir uns definitiv ist also von den
merkmalen einer solchen eines solchen
phänomens her nähern dann ist es gar
nicht so einfach das zu beschreiben was
organisierte kriminalität ist haben zwei
worte in diesem
in diesem in dieser beschreibung das
eine ist kriminalität hardy beginn also
straftaten okay das kann sich jedoch
vorstellen was das ist drogen waffen
menschen und viele andere schlimme dinge
die kriminelle machen können
und dann kommt das organisierte vor
haas' diese kriminalität ist also kein
kein einziges keine einzige straftat ist
kein einmaliges phänomen sondern die
wird wiederholt begannen die wird
organisiert begangen
die wird von mehreren begangen die wird
von über einen längeren zeitraum
begangen
und da sind wir doch schon ziemlich nahe
an dem phänomen was organisierte
kriminalität ist und da können natürlich
bestimmte mittel eingesetzt werden das
kommt den polizeilichen definitionen
auch noch zum ausdruck gewalt
einschüchterung korruption nutzung von
wirtschaftlichen strukturen und so
weiter und an diesen einzelnen merkmalen
sieht man wie viele gesichter
organisierte kriminalität hat die eben
nicht nur aus drogen waffen menschen
besteht sondern alle tätigkeiten
kriminellen tätigkeiten abdeckt und
jetzt kommt mit dem man geld verdienen
kann
jetzt habe ich hier im chat tatsächlich
fast nur kommentare die sich gegen diese
sogenannte kleinkriminalität richten
also solche fragen wie von ava gab es
zusammenhänge zu berliner großfamilien
oder von einem anderen kommentatoren
beherbergt deutschland so viele
staatenlose nachweislich kriminelle
familien und das seit jahrzehnten
also da ist hier der fokus sehr klar auf
diese form der organisierten
kriminalität woran liegt das dass wir
jetzt vor allem da so hinschauen weil
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe gibt es ja
noch ganz ganz andere formen die
vielleicht medial gar nicht so beachtet
werden also sie sprechen mit der
kleinkriminalität im kontext von
organisierter kriminalität natürlich ein
empfindliches thema
lassen sie mich zunächst vielleicht ein
paar zahlen einfach nennen damit dass
auch die zuschauer einordnen können im
letzten bundesliga bild zur
organisierten kriminalität das jährlich
vom bundeskriminalamt herausgegeben wird
reden wir über 579 oka verfahren die in
deutschland geführt werden
da sind auch die klaren verfahren mit
drin und 45 dieser verfahren sind klare
verfahren das
nennt man sogar eines hell fällt also
das was man sehen kann wir wissen ja
nicht was im untergrund ist das ein
merkmal der organisierten kriminalität
wir sind ja jetzt im kontext mit diesen
mit dieser akkreditierung ist ja die
abschottung
das ist ja gerade der witz dass keiner
ist mit kriegen soll also aber das was
wir wissen ist dass jedenfalls mal das
was die strafverfolgungsbehörde
festgestellt haben dass nicht der
großteil der organisierten kriminalität
zur kleinkriminalität gehört aber es
gibt auch organisierte kriminalität die
durch kleinkriminalität auffällt und in
dieser ganzen aktion über die wir gerade
sprechen vom fbi und europol ist heute
etwas die aktion in nordrhein-westfalen
untergegangen also auch im ministerrat
oder eine pressekonferenz gegeben
bei der er mitgeteilt hat dass heute
auch in nordrhein-westfalen aktionen und
aus durchsuchungen gegen kriminelle
klaren mitglieder
es gibt keine kriminellen clans nicht
alle familienmitglieder sind kriminellen
muss man auch deutlich sagen es gibt
kriminelle klaren mitglieder und gegen
diese wurden heute ermittlungen geführt
und es gab das seiner aussage nach auch
festnahmen im hochrangigen bereich das
geht heute so ein bisschen unter in der
ganzen großen aktionen über die wir
gerade spreche das heißt konkret
hochrangige bereich die die anführer
dieser banden oder was meint man damit
nach ja nach aussagen von herrn heuer
soll es sich auch um führende köpfe
gehandelt haben aber verstehen sie ich
kenne die ermittlungen auch nicht ich
habe es nur dann heute auch noch medial
wahrgenommen aber das ist immer die
zweite meldung hinter der großen meldung
die wir über die wir besprechen
ich habe jetzt hier eine frage von
angolaner auf youtube die sich mit den
folgen beschäftigt und zwar wenn es so
viele menschen dort festgenommen werden
vermutlich auch erst mal länger in
untersuchungshaft sitzen ist dann nicht
mit machtkämpfen innerhalb dieser ja
diese organisation zu rechnen also kann
es sein dass es dann irgendwie jetzt
erstmal noch mal richtig knallt und
jeder noch mehr verbrechen im endeffekt
erleben
ja das ist eine prognose die keine
stimmen die kann auch nicht stimmen
die glaskugel habe ich auch nicht das
kommt nämlich darauf an welche personen
sie den festgenommen haben haben sie
tatsächlich die mittlere und die
führungsebene erwischt
dann könnte es tatsächlich zu übernahme
kämpfen führen
wenn sie aber nur das fußvolk erwischt
haben
dann wird es dazu nicht kommen das
glaube ich nicht dass das passieren wird
aber natürlich ist eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit liegt nahe wenn
führende persönlichkeiten dort erwischt
wurden festgenommen wurden
aber was soll man dagegen machen die
aufgabe der polizei und der
kontrollbehörden und
strafverfolgungsbehörden ist
kriminalität zu verfolgen und sie nicht
laufen zu lassen und dementsprechend
muss es richtig sein daneben auch in die
strukturen hinein zu gehen und dann die
führenden köpfe möglichst festzunehmen
es gibt eine andere frage hier von
joachim er möchte wissen ob die behörden
den kriminellen immer noch
hinterherhinken also das klingt
natürlich nach einem sehr effektiven
schlag aber wenn sie sich das angucken
sind die behörden in deutschland
tatsächlich so aufgestellt dass man
sagen kann die kriegen das problem
zunehmend in griff oder sind sie immer
noch dabei die köpfe der hydra
abzuschlagen und die wachsen sofort
wieder nach das ist eine schöne frage
die antwort ist ganz einfach das ist wie
beim hasen und beim igel
es kommt darauf an dass der abstand
zwischen hase und igel nicht zu groß
wird und daran muss man arbeiten und da
muss man sich immer wieder die
stellschrauben im system anschauen man
muss die organisationsstrukturen
anschauen man muss die priorisierung
also welche kriminalitätsbereiche
verfolgt man welche informationen werden
ausgetauscht welche behörden arbeiten
miteinander gibt es best practices also
arbeitsmethoden die sich bewährt haben
bewährte ermittlungsmaßnahmen muss man
rechtlich nach steuern das muss man sich
immer immer wieder anschauen
das ist niemals für ein jahrzehnt
festgeschrieben und dann muss man nichts
mehr machen
da muss man daran arbeiten bedeutet also
abstand zwischen den kriminellen in den
strafverfolgungsbehörden nicht zu groß
werden lassen
aber kriminalität wird man nie ausräumen
können beim wird höchstens versuchen die
ursachen von kriminalität und die
auswirkungen von kriminalität mindern zu
können aber man würde es niemals
ausbeuten
jetzt haben wir auch schon das problem
der verwertbarkeit gerade angesprochen
mit unseren kollegen mrt wissen der
sagte in den usa ist es möglich diese
ganzen chats zu nehmen und daraus
gerichtsverfahren zu stricken
wahrscheinlich zumindest hier in
deutschland wurde uns gesagt haben sich
die sicherheitsbehörden unsicher ob sie
überhaupt mitmachen können bei der
aktion eben weil es eine beihilfe zu
straftaten sein könnte wenn man quasi
diese ja diese plattform zur verfügung
stellt und dann guckt was passiert was
heißt das genau warum sind da deutsche
behörden oder warum sind die dann ist
dem meer die die sind mir die hände
gebunden als den amerikanischen behörden
ja die der grund dafür liegt darin dass
jedes strafrechtssystem jedes land also
in dem gegen kriminalität mit den
mitteln des strafrechts also dem
prozessrecht den ermittlungsmaßnahmen
und dem materiellen strafrechts sprich
also den straftaten die im
strafgesetzbuch beschrieben werden
agiert und das ist sehr kulturell
unterschiedlich ist auch in den
rechtssystemen unterschiedlich und ist
natürlich hier für uns für deutschland
für viele andere länder natürlich auch
verfassungsrechtlich determiniert und in
deutschland gilt also der grundsatz dass
die strafverfolgungsbehörden sollen
straftaten verfolgen sollen sie aber
nicht unterstützen und deshalb sind ihre
informationen durchaus richtig und wenn
das bundeskriminalamt sich dazu geäußert
hat und gesagt hat wir sind uns da
unsicher
dann ist das erst mal die richtige
reaktion die völlig richtige reaktion
denn in einem rechtsstaat muss man den
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen folgen und
kann nicht aus effektivität und
effizienz gesichtspunkten dann alles auf
den kopf stellen das wäre ja
beliebigkeit es wäre willkür und so kann
man nicht agieren aber so als bürger
würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen ich finde
das ganz okay wenn man leute irgendwie
auch mit solchen mitteln erwischt weil
mit welchen mitteln wenn man sie denn
sonst erwischen wenn die alles tun um
das möglichst unter den teppich zu
halten
ja aber der zweck heilige nicht die
mittel
und wir haben in deutschland auch mittel
mit denen man agieren kann und es gab in
ihrer anmoderation ist ja schon
telegramm und whatsapp und messenger
dienste die ja auch verschlüsselt mit
denen man verschlüsselt kommunizieren
kann
die wurden ja bereits genannt und warum
benutzen kriminelle die nicht ja bei
strafverfolgungsbehörden gegenmaßnahmen
haben
das ist der grund und diese
gegenmaßnahmen die stehen in der
strafprozessordnung das ist kein
geheimnis dass man darum herum machen
muss diese gegenmaßnahmen stehen im
paragraf 100a und 100g der
strafprozessordnung dass die sogenannte
quellen-telekommunikationsüberwachung wo
mit einem trojaner in ein it-system
eingegriffen werden kann um dann die
verschlüsselte kommunikation aus zu
leiten oder die sogenannte online
durchsuchung wo ganze systeme gespiegelt
werden können also es ist überhaupt
nicht so dass man in deutschland nichts
tun könnte hier ist da war das
praktische problem wie kriege ich den
trojaner denn draußen das rechtliche
problem ist dahinter steht ist ein
verfassungsrechtliches aber jetzt bitte
nicht als problem verstehen sondern das
sind die verfassungsrechtlichen
garantien dass eben nicht jeder mein
gerät ausspionieren darf sondern dass
man dafür eine sogenannte nennt man
juristen sprachgebrauch
ermächtigungsgrundlage braucht und wer
macht ermächtigungsgrundlagen für
grundrechtseingriffe das spüren wir ja
alle jeden tag in der korona pandemie
alles was uns durch verordnungen
aufgegeben wird sind
grundrechtseingriffe und die brauchen
eine rechtfertigung und im bereich des
strafprozessrechts bedarf es dieser
rechtfertigung durch ein
parlamentsgesetz da müssen sich alle im
parlament darüber streiten ob das
richtig ist dass man das so macht und
dann würde in einer abstimmung wird dann
abgestimmt so dass also jetzt nicht in
den händen der polizei liegen kann zu
sagen okay wir machen mal diese mal darf
der zweck heiligt die mittel
das ist der inbegriff des rechtsstaats
dass solche tiefgehenden entscheidungen
von einem parlament getroffen werden und
dass in deutschland eine polizeibehörde
eine solche
ein solches gerät via nun jetzt
entwickelt mit einer entsprechenden
software
das ist nicht gibt es nicht da dafür
gibt es keine richtigen gut aber dafür
gibt es keinen parlamentarischen diskurs
der an einem gesetz gemündet wonach man
so etwas machen war das einzige
demokratie und unseren rechtsstaat
ausmacht das heißt im endeffekt waren
jetzt aber die ermittlungsbehörden
deutschland darauf angewiesen dass sie
die informationen aus dem ausland
bekommen haben
aber auch da gibt es ja die frage ist
das überhaupt in ordnung also es gibt ja
wie sie schon sagten diesen diesen
engadget dieses engadget verfahren da
sind gerade ermittelt und da gibt es ein
zitat von dem kölner rechtsanwalt der
nutzer von dieser ein quad plattform
vertritt und er sagt also man kann nicht
einfach hier auf shoppingtour gehen
einem rechtsstaat und beweismittel in
einem anderen land zu bestellen
für die behörden mehr befugnisse haben
könnte es tatsächlich dazu kommen dass
du jetzt weil diese ganzen menschen
festgesetzt haben dass wir diese geräte
haben aber dass dann hinterher rauskommt
wir können diese verfahren nicht
durchführen weil die art und weise wie
die ermittlungsbehörden kenntnis erlangt
haben über diese straftaten die wahrheit
nicht legal
das kann passieren ja aber bei dieser
kurzen antwort möchte ich nicht stehen
bleiben enkel chat ich hatte auch
erläutert dass es dort französische
strafverfolgungsbehörden waren die
dieses verschlüsselungssystem geknackt
haben und dann den datenfluss und die
kommunikation aus geleitet habe und
ausgewertet haben und jetzt muss man
sehen
in frankreich gibt es ermittlungen im
bereich organisierte kriminalität also
und dem terrorismus bereich ohne
anfangsverdacht
dort kann man also solche dinge machen
ohne dass es einen anfangsverdacht gibt
das gibt es in deutschland nicht
und jetzt ist die frage und da aus
dieser überlegung resultiert dann auch
das zitat das sie genannt haben kann
also ein beweis der in einem land legal
erhoben wurde in einem anderen land
legal verwertet werden
grundsätzlich ja es sei denn die art und
weise der beweiserhebung widerspricht zu
grundsätzen
so tiefgehend dem eigenen rechtssystem
hiermit deutschland dass man das nicht
hinnehmen kann und ich sage ihnen
ehrlich das werden gerichte entscheiden
und im engadget zusammenhang gibt es
gerichtsentscheidungen schon dazu in
haft sachen und wir werden auch in
diesem fall der liegt ja ein bisschen
anders weil hier eine us-amerikanische
behörde die daten erhoben hat und nicht
im polizeilichen vereinfachten
übermittlung sweg wie das und
europäischen union möglich ist die daten
erstmal übertragen wurden
die dann und jetzt wird's komplex und
kompliziert wird sie das dann im wege
einer europäischen ermittlungs anordnung
dann nochmal bestätigt werden müssen
hier ist der ganz normale rechtshilfeweg
entscheidend und dann wissen wir auch
noch zu wenig wie wir kennen jetzt die
pressemitteilung auch von europol die
online steht zu diesem komplex wir
kennen die akten nicht wir kennen nicht
gegen schon identifizierte personen die
die das denen diese geräte verkauft
wurden das also schon gegen die ein
anfangsverdacht bestand oder wurde da
ganz breit gestreut denn eins ist ja
auch klar nicht jeder der verschlüsselt
kommuniziert ist ein verbrecher
also da habe ich erkennen dass in
zahlreichen zusammenhängen
da habe ich hier auch ist kommen die
daten sind noch mal auch ganz klar
gesagt werden
da habe ich ja auch ein kommentar von
tannin der siemens solche mittel könnten
auch mal gegen andersdenkende politisch
motiviert genutzt werden und so weiter
gerade deutschland muss bei solchen
mitteln aufgrund seiner geschichte acht
geben das wird auch ist auch mit der
grund glaube ich warum das hier in
deutschland eher skeptisch betrachtet
wird
jetzt habe ich hier einige
missverständnisse die würde ich ganz
gern noch mal kurz ausräumen vielleicht
können sie mir auch dann zur seite gehen
also einmal gibt es noch mal einen
kommentar so viele ich jetzt mitbekommen
habe fanden die meisten razzien in
deutschland statt was sagt uns das über
die arbeit des verfassungsschutzes da
muss man differenzieren der
verfassungsschutz hat mit organisierter
kriminalität überhaupt nichts zu tun
das sind völlig verschiedene
straftatbestände und die meisten razzien
fanden meines wissens auch nicht in
deutschland statt oder haben sie da
andere informationen
also es ist natürlich richtig der
verfassungsschutz der hat erst mal
nichts mit der organisierten
kriminalität zu tun
die beschäftigen sich im inland mit der
datenerhebung und mit dem
gefährdungslage bild verschiedener
extrem aus strömungen dass die
beschäftigen sich also nicht mit
organisierter kriminalität wobei auch
organisierte kriminalität ein politisch
motivierte kriminalität durchaus
schnittmengen haben können aber das
sollte vielleicht an der stelle erst mal
genügend zusagen dass der
verfassungsschutz hier keine keine
priorisierung sieht in seinen
tätigkeiten und auch versichert keine
priorisierung in anspruch nimmt
was die frage der ermittlungen und der
razzien angeht wissen wir von europol es
handelte sich um 800 weltweit und davon
70 waren in deutschland wenn ich es
richtig erinnere also ungefähr ja nicht
mal zehn prozent ich habe hier einige
kommentare die finde ich schwierig ich
kann nachvollziehen was eure da gedanken
sind es wird jetzt die immer so ich sag
mal so ein link hergestellt herr
professor sind zwischen organisierter
kriminalität und politiker innen und und
comex geschäften und was wir da wirecard
haben also ein großer komplex wo es hier
verdächtigt wird von mehreren
kommentatoren deswegen spreche ich das
auch an wir sind ja hier auch eine
transparent arbeiten der sendung und
ignorieren nicht sachen die irgendwie
vielleicht mal unangenehm sein können
aber deswegen sprechen wir auch darüber
mit experten also es wird quasi so einen
zusammenhang gestellt zwischen
organisierter kriminalität politikern
parteien und solchen sachen die halt
bankbetrug comex wirecard fällt so was
erstens in ihrem in ihrer definition
auch in organisierte qualität zum
beispiel so comex geschäfte oder dieser
wirecard skandal
und was ist quasi ja an der vermengung
mit der politik dran
also die polizeiliche definition zur
organisierten kriminalität aus dem jahr
die hat bestimmte einzelne generelle
merkmale die artig genannt müssen
mindestens drei personen sein die müssen
auf dauer straftaten begehen wollen
organisatorischen zusammenschluss haben
und dann gibt es besondere merkmale und
eines dieser besonderen merkmale ist die
einflussnahme auf politik also das kann
über gewalt das kann über einflussnahme
in form der korruption geschehen also
das ist schon mit drin
auch auf justiz übrigens und was wir im
hellfeld sehen sind das ganz wenig fälle
in denen es jedenfalls in helfe also wo
man nachweise dafür hat dass in
deutschland der bereich der
organisierten kriminalität im
zusammenhang mit politik eine rolle
spielt das ist in anderen ländern
sicherlich ganz anders der zweite
fragenkomplex oder diese zweite seite
der frage ist die der zusammenhang
zwischen wirtschaftskriminalität und
organisierte kriminalität und den sehe
ich und diesen zusammen haben den muss
man stärker beleuchten das ist auch eine
forderung von mir dass man gerade im
kontext wirecard und andere
auffälligkeiten auch der frage nachgehen
muss ist das nicht organisierte
kriminalität ich habe in den
stellungnahmen und in den berichten die
ich über bayer grad höre höre ich immer
den geschäftsmäßigen und bandenmäßigen
betrug wissen sie eigentlich ist das
organisierte kriminalität in der band er
versteckt sich nämlich eine ganze menge
von krimineller vereinigung von
organisierter kriminalität aber das wird
dann immer rechtlich als banken
kriminalität ausgegeben obwohl man
rechtlich und auch da ist das deutsche
recht nicht schlecht aufgestellt mit
einer bestimmten vorschrift im
strafgesetzbuch auf die kriminelle
vereinigung hier
demnach gehen müsste hier ermitteln
müsste strukturen aufdecken müsste und
dann auch im prozess genau dieses delikt
mit anklagen im kontext einiger dieser
großen verfahren habe ich das noch nicht
gesehen und das halte ich für ein
versäumnis herr professor sind vielen
dank für ihre ausführungen und ihre
erklärungen heute abend zu diesem sehr
komplexen thema wahrscheinlich werden
wir im zuge dieser ermittlungen jetzt
öfter noch mal darüber reden für heute
sage ich aber vielen dank und findet
grüßen nach osnabrück und auch an euch
vielen dank dabei seien fürs beantworten
unserer nähe fürs frage stellen suchen
wir haben eure fragen versucht zu
beantworten er hat fragen gestellt
ein sehr komplexes sehr spannendes thema
wir bleiben auf jeden fall dran für euch
und sagen dafür heute macht gut bis zum
nächsten mal
und tschüss